Hi everyone,
I'm Scarlett Johansson
and I'm here with
my Black Widow co-stars,
Florence Pugh
and David Harbour.
Back together again.
♪
(exclaims)
We're gathered here today
to look at your Tweets
and guess which one of us
the Tweet is about.
-Let's do this.
-"Can we talk about
the immaculate
music taste ____ has."
I know that's not me.
It's probably, like, Florence.
But "immaculate" is a bit
too squeaky clean.
(all exclaim)
I knew it, it's so cool, right?
Okay, "Wait, I just found out
____ is a twin.
Was this common knowledge?"
Scarlett,
it's about Scarlett.
Yeah, Scarlett,
she's the twin.
Me, me, me, me.
"Just came here to state
my excitement
about ____ doing
a Russian accent
in the Black Widow trailer.
I'm in."
-Rachel?
-I was gonna say Rachel too.
Aw, come on.
(laughter)
Come on, you're gonna
give this one to Rachel Weisz?
None of you are excited
about my Russian accent.
-I think it's me.
-I imitate it all the time!
I'm gonna go double down on me.
Who is it?
-David Harbour.
-Yes!
Oh!
Justice, vindication.
Sorry, we can move on.
(laughing)
I have a lot of energy.
"I'm obsessed with
_____'s tea tutorial."
That's gotta be Florence.
Yeah, that's me. That's me.
Do you make like
cups of tea and stuff?
Yeah. Yeah.
Do you put the milk in first
like the British--
No! That is crazy.
Is that a serious question?
"Can you believe it,
the Earth is a billion years old
and you manage to live
the same time as..."
Yeah, that's Scarlett,
because I feel that too.
Me too.
What's that supposed to mean?
I don't understand this Tweet.
Basically, someone's
really happy that they're living
in the same period of time
as you.
Oh, right, as opposed
to like medieval times?
"Why does ____'s
New York loft
look like my entire Pinterest?"
That's David.
Yeah, that's David.
And, you know, that's
like a 13-year-old girl
who's saying that.
I showed that to my designer.
I was like, "Here.
This is Allison
from junior high's Pinterest.
I want it to look
exactly like that."
♪